welcome to hannity now tonight we have a
number of major breaking news stories we
will cover them all
including another insane anti-trump
conspiracy theory
by congressman well the cowardly ship
himself
now a huge development tonight in the
mueller witch hunt
also an update on the massive college
admissions scandal
and we'll continue our hannity watch on
the radical 2020 democrats that would
like to be president
with an investigation into beto bozo
robert francis o'rourke from the ground
in his home state of texas but first we
get started with our roundup of this
week's worst moments from the radical
democratic hopefuls for president
something the mainstream media we know
they will never do
now it's only tuesday but the dozen far
left candidates running to replace
president trump
getting off to a rough start now take
for example senator elizabeth warren
and senator kirsten gillibrand they
don't like that president trump was able
to successfully select
two original supreme court justices so
now they want to get rid of the supreme
court as we
have it currently configured both
senators told politico that they're open
to increasing the amount of supreme
court justices
this would give them the ability to
stack the co court
with far left activist justices thereby
leaving
the third coequal branch of government
well fairly powerless constantly under
the thumb
of the executive branch this is beyond
unethical it is unconstitutional it is a
clear power grab
but what else do we expect from
elizabeth warren
she's been rigging the system for years
getting ahead by lying
about her ancestry and let's not forget
about
corey spartacus booker he's also taking
a brave stand against the scary supreme
court
watch this eric holder the former ag
is talking about expanding the number of
people in the united states supreme
court beyond nine to get more
progressives on there where are you on
that
um i i think we need to fix the supreme
court i think they stole a supreme court
seat can we keep it at nine should we
keep it at nine
i think i would like to start exploring
a lot of options and we should have a
national conversation term limits for
supreme court justices might be one
thing to give every president to the
ability to choose three
uh with people holding on to those seats
in ways that i don't think is
necessarily healthy
you may want to note that spartacus he
wasn't demanding term limits for his own
position as a u.s senator now just the
supreme court where kavanaugh
gorsuch and clarence thomas preside now
of course this
is part of a classic far left tactic
when you can't win
an election based on ideas and policy at
the ballot box
they just go to rigging the system which
is why elizabeth warren is vowing to
dismantle
well the very way we even elect a
president doesn't work in her favor
take a look my view
is that every vote
matters and the way we can make that
happen
is that we can have national
voting and that means get rid of the
electoral
college
sure let's let new york new jersey
massachusetts illinois and california
determine
every president you see she doesn't want
the every vote to count
in other words she wants to ignore all
of the states in the middle of the
country
the red states of course no more
electoral college
no more supreme court as we know it
checks and balances thrown to the wind
but of course if democrats get their way
well third trimester abortion
including infanticide during and after
birth well that would be perfectly legal
and readily available sadly they're
fighting for that
it will protect infanticide seemingly
above all else
naturally this includes beto bozo
robert francis o'rourke let's take a
look
are you for or against third trimester
abortions so
the question is about abortion and
reproductive rights
and and my answer to you is that that
should be a decision that the woman
makes
uh about her own body um
i trust her um but that's my answer
first we'll deliver the baby the
governor of the commonwealth of virginia
said
and we'll make sure the baby's
comfortable then we'll let the mother
decide
unbelievable and they call trump immoral
and every other name in the book
and they told you that justice kavanaugh
was a monster
but almost every democrat now running
for president cheers
for this issue of infanticide think
about that
now meanwhile they try to shame
conservatives for what wanting border
security
want to stop drugs from crossing our
border controlled immigration
on monday senator gillibrand said
there's no such thing as
an illegal human
take a look immigration is not
a security issue it is an economic and a
humanitarian and a family issue
there is no such thing as an illegal
human
beito wants to get rid of all walls on
the southern border gillibrand wants
open borders no walls no checks no
nothing
and she even wants to abolish
immigration and customs enforcement
and that's not all she's promising to
pay for an influx of illegal immigrants
through
the green new deal you know the one that
promises to turn
america into a socialist utopian take
away all your fears
and the government will control the
means of production like in
energy and health care estimated costs
as high as 94 trillion dollars in the
process in 10 years
and keep in mind our entire federal
budget last year was roughly 4 trillion
dollars
democrats they shouldn't they say we
don't have to worry about the costs
they want to worry about the planet not
being burned up in
12 years they want government-run health
care government paid for higher
education for all
government paid for vacations family
leads sponsored healthy food
government healthy food okay uh
government monthly income for everybody
whether you're willing or unwilling to
work
and government forced building
renovation every building in the country
each and every building for energy
efficiency and of course the end of all
fossil fuels and cows and planes in 10
years
and gillibrand supports that okay so
does elizabeth warren
take a look when you take a look at the
green new deal
understand this is about building the
infrastructure for the 21st century
for a sustainable world right at the
same town hall
warren proposed over 100 trillion
dollars
in new spending a hundred trillion
that's 94 trillion
more dollars in the entire 2018 federal
budget
the green new deal is insane and would
guarantee
poverty and a dying country and economy
now nearly every 20 20 democrats
supports it including spartacus
and despite supporting the biggest
socialist takeover in the history
of earth senator spartacus wants you to
know that he's not a socialist
but what do you call it then take a look
i
am for capitalism i'm tired of companies
engaging in socialism
where they outsource all right that's
where they outsource their ideas they
outsource their ideas that's a good
return
i am not a socialist we've got people in
the party who are i i am a democrat i
believe in fundamental democratic
principles
even matthews is laughing now booker's a
perfect representation of what is a
radical socialist extreme
democrat and this entire field for that
matter this party now has become
so far left even liberal business people
andrew yang for example is gaining
traction
for promising to give every american one
thousand dollars
each and every month doubling our
federal budget in the process
and tonight the field of far left
candidates is about to grow even more
crowded
according to the wall street journal
well creepy crazy
uncle joe biden is telling supporters he
plans on running
we'll have more on that later but first
we do have some good news
our hannity watch on the mueller witch
hunt another top prosecutor is
reportedly leaving the special counsel's
investigation
now this comes after so-called pitbull
andrew weissman
announced his resignation a few days ago
this is yet another sign that the
investigation hopefully
finally is almost over and according to
reports many republicans
and those in the administration well
they're looking forward to mueller's
findings
meanwhile democrats they now seem very
anxious
that's because trump russia collusion
was is and forever will be a hoax
and if mueller is a decent honest man
with reverence for our laws constitution
well the absurd collusion narrative will
be put to rest once and for all but
we know that's not not going to happen
because the biggest liar in congress
and leaker himself we cowardly shift who
won't come on this program i've offered
him four hours three hours of radio one
hour of tv
and he won't take us up on our offer
well he's been spreading conspiracy
theories about
rush russia and trump for eternity now
and now he'll use the platform as the
house intel chair in order to align the
president
with endless mccarthy ask investigations
and recently schiff told nbc news that
the counterintelligence investigation
into the trump campaign is important
because quote
it goes to a present threat toward
national security
whether the president and anybody around
him are compromised by a foreign power
okay well a sitting congressman chair of
the house
intel committee recklessly pushing a
conspiracy theory
that a foreign government is controlling
our country
without evidence he should be ashamed of
himself but of course he's not
like most democrats their unrelenting
hatred
24 7 for president trump that overrules
all common decency logic common sense
schiff and other democrats
they want the president to fail even if
that means america will fail in the
process